oh okay answer this
what do you see what young girl
posing with a bag of popcorn what
oh oh whoa whoa whoa whoa
no that took now i can't don't see the
popcorn
that blew my mind oh what
how's it going bro beard pat today we're
looking at confusing perspectives
i love and hate these okay wait
let's look at it first i have no idea it
looks like a parking lot
shot of burning man that looks like a
solar system okay
i get that no they didn't do it for me
maybe did it for you
that's the fun oh god what oh it looks
like we're falling but it's literally
just bookcases
any interstellar fans out here that's
actually what they did to create the
tesseract
fun fact that just looks sick picture of
a pool
underwater during rain upside
down oh my god
okay didn't blow my mind but aesthetic
as hell i thought these were small
bushes in gravel flower bed nope boston
protest 2020.
damn it i saw the people first damn it
okay oh this is such a good one
where's the rest of her where is she
she's in the ground
pull her out oh wait that's a wall right
there
i remember watching this and someone
told me hey there's a wall
i'm like there's no wall she's coming
out of the ground
it makes no sense okay
i thought that was a dog isn't it oh
whoa it's a guy
it looks like a dog is gaming and he's
like what are you guys doing over there
stop messing around we got a game to win
what is this
what if you turn the chicago bullet slug
upside down
it looks like a robot effing a crap what
you're making me do this hold up loading
photoshop
okay i don't oh
you spread that crap and crab ass is why
dude let's go
god oh
god oh i got a hiccup now for damn it
okay what is happening
what is this i was trying to figure out
why this guy wouldn't stop staring at me
from his car
[Laughter]
turns out it's just an advertisement
on the car behind it oh my gosh dude
damn it i got a hiccup all right if you
ever have a hiccup here's
how you get rid of it just think don't
hiccup
sheer willpower don't hiccup
[ __ ] what dog put his head inside a dog
oh
looks like a dark souls monster the sky
is missing some pixels
damn it you just gotta drink
you know what we did as kids to get rid
of hiccups
and it actually worked i don't know if i
can do it
you would let me see if i can try
wait i think it went away oh my god it
went away
great all right don't have to do it uh
we would
make a handstand against a wall and then
you would drink something upside down
and that would work
100 of the time but now i can't show it
by my sheer willpower i
removed my hiccups whoa wow
that's kind of that's just a cool shot
whoa oh my god
whoa i thought i got it but i didn't get
it and then when i got it it blew my
mind
i thought it was just like oh haha funny
perspective she looks so big next to the
guy
oh whoa
[Music]
oh dude i love this [ __ ] okay
it's bugs what i don't get it
whoa it's people it's not bugs
oh man i was like it's obviously bugs
hello
idiots oh
man it's people dancing oh damn i
read the title and i still didn't get it
dude i love this subreddit
what about this
it's a it's a remote control car i can
tell
yeah this one got me good it didn't get
me [ __ ] because i'm too
smart just like i'm smart enough to
remove my own hiccups
that's brain power
huh i thought i was tripping so i
recorded it
that's kind of cool
[Laughter]
reflections how do they work just the
guy wearing a hoodie
huh sorry what i don't
i don't see the hoodie and i'm scared
i'm scared this is a gift that's gonna
turn into a jump scare
hello there's no hoodie what do you mean
[Music]
i don't ha
what do you mean are you trolling oh
it's his head laying on the side not a
collar
sorry what wow
that took me so long oh of course he's
laying on
it's just a guy wearing a hoodie it's
just a guy
wearing a hoodie dude i don't know if i
have the strength to
go on okay
[Laughter]
it's like a weird joke like there's a
setup
you don't know but you don't know what
the line is i think that's what makes it
so funny and it's completely
unintentional and uh unpretentious
oh dude i guess camo does work
damn uh the joke oh you're wearing camo
i can't see you well i am
joke's on you okay this is a upside down
oh it's so trippy it's so trippy though
so i flip it so i can feel normal oh
wait i don't get to see it then never
mind don't give them the pleasure
side don't give them the satisfaction if
you can see a beach ocean sky
rocks and stars then you're an artist
okay but it's not a painting
it's lower part of the car gate which
needs to be
thanks for the compliment of being an
artist
what did you say tell me if you guys i
want to know if you see the same [ __ ]
oh that's a horse i had two horses of
course
can i show that out yeah i can yes i can
it's horses nothing else never wear
clothes the same color as your chair
i love it because it's japan and who
knows maybe he is wearing that shirt
like that but the other guy doesn't have
a chair i'm so confused
i i don't see the chair at all i think
this one is better if i don't see the
chair so
oh oh uh
huh uh-huh
where's the tail
i see it okay there is no tail
it came from the water never seen
nothing like it oh what
i'm sorry what oh no
what oh got it
uh it's two set of stairs too flat of
stairs got it okay
uh oh that's just cute
i like that i feel violated we're going
there i'm like
i'm getting fooled every second i don't
know much more i can stomach
oh no no i i've seen this but even even
the first time i saw it i didn't see
jupiter
it's just looking through it like a
binocular or something
they could rename this this subreddit
like strange boss battles or something
bodyless cow cannot produce milk will
steal it from your pockets if you're not
careful
alpha wearing sunglasses i mean that's
all right
the surreal puddle in the parking garage
i've seen this
sorry what oh
damn that's really cool there's more
water than you think
that's the trick right reflection of the
lamp on the sunglasses that's great
all right let's do a couple more this is
a puddle
damn so cool
[Laughter]
that was a journey and i was with them
the sun did as good the sun gave your
friend
a um
damn that's some straight lines right
there let's just go
all right all right all right cut i
can't i can't i
it's too much for me i'll have to edit
there thank you for watching if you
enjoyed smash
like subscribe for more videos and i'll
see you bros tomorrow with another video